good afternoon everyone
i'm here with dr hinshaw to provide an
update on covet 19.
the numbers we're sharing today are from
tuesday april 19th to monday april 25th
our teams at alberta health continue to
closely monitor all available data from
the province including wastewater
surveillance
pcr test positivity and of course
hospital admissions
i'm pleased to report that we continue
to see signs of slowing transmission in
alberta over the past week our average
positivity rate is 25.7
that's slower than most of the past
month
and signals that we may be plateauing
wastewater signals remain high at many
sites including calgary but some areas
are seeing a decline or plateau over the
past week
that includes edmonton red deer canmore
banff and grand prairie
edmonton has seen high levels recently
but the level has dropped sharply in the
past week now it's too soon to know if
it's a start of a sustained downward
trend
but the signs are hopeful
and the surrounding communities in the
capital region are seeing a much slower
increase than in the initial omicron
wave
as is always the case even if
transmission is slowing as it appears to
be hospital emissions will continue to
rise for a few weeks
hospitalizations have risen by about
eight percent over the last week while
the number of people in intensive care
has remained about the same
overall hospital admissions are up
slightly but are still in line with
pre-covered years
we're now
about five weeks in the ba2 driven surge
and transmission and we can see that the
impact is much less than the initial
omicron wave especially when it comes to
hospital admissions other provinces are
experiencing a similar trend in ontario
for example it appears that va2
circulation has plateaued and begun to
drop with a much lower overall impact on
emissions compared to the va1 wave
this is a testament to the power of
vaccines so i want to thank every
albertan
who has been vaccinated and boosted
against covin
your choice is helping to keep
hospitalizations low and ensure that
others can get the medical care and
treatments that they need
while covert admissions are not driving
the same capacity challenges in previous
waves our hospitals remain under
significant pressures
several of our largest sites in
emptiness and in calgary are over 100
occupancy and emergency departments and
ems are under real strength
now it's not new and it's not unique to
alberta the reality is that two years of
coven 19 is straining health care
services in every provinces including
here
if you just look at the numbers on paper
the fact is we've seen these kind of
strains before
you'll you can look at the data from
five years ago under the previous
government ten years ago thirty years
ago
the reality is that hospitals in canada
historically run at ninety percent
occupancy and higher especially in the
big cities and at peak times they run
over one hundred percent
what we have not seen before is two
years of continuous pressure and stress
on the workforce from the pandemic
including those workers who are sick
with coving
so we need to add capacity we need to
get through the current surge of coveted
cases but we also need to do more than
just get back to normal
the normal capacity we had before the
pandemic was not good enough and we need
to do better we need to add capacity so
the system is not under so much strain
even when we're not in a pandemic
and we're doing that we're adding
capacity across our entire health care
system from ems right through to
continuing care
for now
as we look at the current stage of cases
from the ba2 subvariant we're watching
what's happening in other countries
particularly those who've had omicron
longer than we've had it here and we're
seeing it's beginning to recede
in countries like denmark the uk south
africa and in ireland
that
reinforces our expectation from our own
data and from other provinces like
ontario that were likely near peak in
transmission and then in hospital
emissions
but we're not there yet
covet is still here it remains a
significant risk particularly for
unvaccinated people
which is why we continue to make
vaccines readily available across our
entire province
when it comes to vaccination over the
last month we've made
fourth doses for more albertans most at
risk for severe outcomes
and i'm pleased to see that the uptake
is increasing with more than 21 000
fourth doses administered over the last
week
ahs is working with operators to get
doses to residents and long-term care
and designated supported living
facilities
if you or a loved one are eligible for a
fourth dose and it's been at least five
months since your third one please book
an appointment today
in addition to vaccines which provide
the best protection against coven 19
we're working to make treatments such as
paxloved more broadly accessible
as supply has increased we've expanded
eligibility so more albertans can
benefit from this treatment and made it
accessible to more pharmacies
we're also working towards making it
more broadly available by prescription
like other medications
work is underway to transition the
prescribing process to primary care
family physicians are getting tools and
education to ensure they're comfortable
prescribing this medication and i hope
to announce very soon that prescribing
will be fully transferred to them
early uptake of this treatment has been
limited in alberta and across canada
generally however thanks to increased
access and awareness over the last few
weeks about 1300 prescriptions have now
been administered that's nearly double
where we were just two weeks ago
i know there are albertans who are not
currently eligible who are keen to
access this drug
but just a reminder paxlobit is subject
to specific criteria for access because
it's a complex drug with many potential
contraindications and drug interactions
it's appropriate for all for a certain
defined group of patients and even
within that group it may or may not be
appropriate for a given patient
the core clinical criteria are common to
all provinces and they're based on the
best available evidence we'll continue
to monitor the evidence and adjust if
and as appropriate
given the evidence and expert advice as
of today we want albertans who may
benefit from pax love it to know about
it and access it
if it's appropriate for them
if you or someone you know may be
eligible please call healthily as soon
as symptoms develop and please continue
to take precautions best suited to your
unique situation and risk factors and
what's best for your family and loved
ones while the virus remains high in our
communities
and if you're in a setting with measures
in place to protect vulnerable people do
the right thing
respect and follow the rules
if you're going to a hospital
visiting a continuing care facility or
taking public transit wear a mask
be prepared to wear a mask at your
doctor's office in other health settings
to keep those locations safe for
everyone and if you tested positive or
have symptoms stay home and isolate away
from others
these simple acts have and will continue
to help slow transmission in the
province and turn our conscious optimism
into a reality
so thank you again for
all albertans are doing to be able to
protect themselves in each other and
once again thank you to our healthcare
workers who are working through these
very challenging times and with that i
now invite dr hinshaw
thank you minister and good afternoon
everyone
before i speak about covent today i want
to address some questions we've been
getting about cases of severe hepatitis
or liver inflammation in children that
have been reported in several countries
around the world
what we know right now is that roughly
170 cases of sudden liver inflammation
in children aged 16 and under have been
reported globally mostly in european
countries and the united states
while this is a small number
unfortunately about 17 of these cases
have gone on to need a liver transplant
and sadly one has died
there are many causes for hepatitis but
in these cases the most common causes
have been ruled out and it is not clear
what led to the condition
there have been no confirmed cases in
alberta to date and we are working to
provide information to front line
physicians on this topic
there is a great deal of work being done
on this globally and some cases have had
an adenovirus which is a common cold
virus identified
it is not clear if this virus is causing
the hepatitis but it is one possible
cause that is being explored
for parents in alberta who may be
worried about this i want to underline
the point that this is a very rare
condition with only about 170 cases
identified
if there is an infectious cause of this
syndrome the same things we have been
doing as parents over the last two years
will still be valuable now
such as reminding our kids to clean
their hands regularly and continuing to
support the important practice of
encouraging everyone in our circles to
stay home when feeling sick
using masks in public places is an
option for families who wish to add an
extra layer of protection
we're working closely with federal
provincial and territorial partners to
monitor emerging information and we'll
keep albertans informed of any
developments
for today's covet update between tuesday
april 19th to monday april 25th
our pcr test positivity ranged from 23.4
to 30.6
with an average of 25.7
for the week
this is stable from the previous week
as the minister mentioned
hospitalizations have increased slightly
currently there are
1220 people with covid19 in hospital
including 47 in the icu
sadly between april 19th and april 25th
an average of nine deaths per day
related to covet 19 were reported to
alberta health
by comparison u.s data estimates that
prior to covit there was an average of
one death per day per two million people
for influenza and rsv combined
which would work out to about two to
three deaths per day in alberta on
average
clearly covet is still something we need
to be very mindful of
the individuals who whose deaths were
reported in the last week were between
the ages of 32 and 103
my deepest sympathies are with their
loved ones and anyone in alberta who has
lost someone they cared about no matter
the cause
as kovit continues to circulate in our
communities and some albertans continue
to experience severe outcomes i want to
review the options available to help
albertans prevent serious outcomes and
treat covet 19 infections
vaccination remains the single most
effective tool we have to reduce the
risk of experiencing severe illness
hospitalization and death
even against the va ii variant vaccines
are effective at preventing these
worst-case scenarios
that is why we continue to urge
albertans to get every dose they're
eligible for
as the minister has mentioned this inc
also includes fourth doses for all
albertans aged 70 and older first
nations inuit and metis people aged 65
and older all residents and seniors
congregate care facilities and those
with serious immune compromising
conditions as long as a minimum of five
months have passed since their third
dose
while on the topic of vaccines i would
like to advise albertans that after this
week astrazeneca products will no longer
be available in canada with respect to
covert 19 vaccines
several other vaccine options exist
including moderna and pfizer which are
the preferred options and of which
alberta has ample supply
in addition alberta also continues to
have some jansen and novavax vaccines
available for those who may need or
prefer a non-mrna vaccine
while i continue to stress the
importance of receiving a full series of
vaccine
as the minister mentioned we are also
working to improve access to paxlovid
for those who can benefit from it most
we have had a lot of questions about the
eligibility for this prescription oral
antiviral treatment that can help reduce
the risk of severe disease in some
individuals
it is important to remember that
determining who can benefit most from
this medication
depends on who is most at risk of severe
outcomes right now with any medication
including paxlovit it is important to
consider what benefit a medication can
provide and also what the potential side
effects are
for someone at high risk of severe
outcomes such as an older person with no
vaccine protection
the benefit of early treatment in
reducing the risk of severe outcomes is
large
balancing out the risk of side effects
for most people in this group
for someone with a lower risk of severe
outcomes such as someone with a full
series of vaccine plus all boosters they
are eligible for
the benefit of paxlovit is less since
they have a lower risk to begin with
this is true for most people even if
they have a condition like diabetes
because vaccines still provide good
protection against severe outcomes
this means the side effects from
paxlovid may be worse for them than the
covert risk
there's also been some confusion about
the difference between
immunocompromising conditions and
chronic conditions so i want to address
that as well
people who have immunocompromising
conditions like being on cancer
treatment or post transplant medications
that stop the immune system from working
fully
still benefit significantly from
vaccines but not as much as those whose
immune systems aren't being impacted by
this kind of medication
this means that people in this category
are eligible for this early treatment
independent of how many vaccine doses
they have had
because their immune systems respond
differently to vaccines than other
people
i want to stress that vaccines are still
important for this group and at the same
time they can benefit more from paxlovit
than people who have a condition like
heart disease or diabetes and who are
fully immunized
people living in long-term care or
designated supportive living regardless
of vaccination status may also benefit
from oral antivirals given their
combination of older age and medical
complexity
another consideration in using
antivirals like pacslovic is how its use
may lead to antiviral resistance
the more widely we use medications
against viruses or bacteria the greater
the chance is that that particular tool
will lose effectiveness in the long term
so using it in those who benefit most is
also most likely to keep its usefulness
intact for as long as possible
oral antivirals also have many
interactions with commonly prescribed
medications
and physicians and pharmacists are well
positioned to support patients when
considering whether this treatment is a
good option for them
albertans who have covid19 symptoms and
meet the eligibility criteria listed at
ahs.ca slash covid opt
should book a test right away as
treatment should begin soon after the
start of symptoms
if you test positive please call the
dedicated health link line to be
assessed for outpatient treatments such
as paxlovit
if you are eligible you will be referred
to a physician with the outpatient
treatment program who will determine
what treatment will be of greatest
benefit and either issue a prescription
for paxlovit or book an appointment for
around deservier infusion
as of april 1st all pharmacies can
dispense paxlovit if they choose to do
so
albertans can check the alberta
bluecross website to see which
pharmacies in their area are dispensing
paxlovit and work with their prescriber
to have the prescription sent there
all pharmacies have been reminded of
their obligation to support patients and
to refer them to other pharmacies if
they are unable to dispense paxlovid
within the timelines necessary to start
treatment
pacslovid is an extra line of defense
that can help some people with their
covert 19 infection but we should not
and cannot solely depend on it to get us
through
as has been the case since day one with
this virus we need to use many different
tactics to address covid19
what these are may differ depending on
our comfort levels risk tolerance
and personal risks but being vaccinated
with every dose we are eligible for
staying home when sick and wearing masks
and crowded indoor public spaces will
all make a difference in helping to
break the chains of transmission in our
communities thank you and we're happy to
take questions
thanks dr hinshaw and minister uh no one
in person here at the federal building
in edmonton so we'll go straight to the
phone uh first caller please
we're headed for smith global news
my next question is for dr hinshaw and i
apologize i will just put some chips in
time out so i will try to
do it for you i'm wondering about your
reaction to the decision um from a
calgary judge regarding
your ability to claim cabinet confidence
with the ruling i'm wondering if you can
answer the questions
um that justice remains laid out
including
did the premier and cabinet ever direct
you to more severe restrictions than
recommended would they ever force you to
impose more severe restrictions on
certain groups and did you ever
recommend that restrictions should be
eased only to have that advice ignored
that's a matter that's still before the
court so i'm not able to comment on that
at this time
thanks audrey and i'll bring out a
follow-up
do you have any in general comments
regarding the decision by justice remain
my understanding is that the legal team
is looking at the decision but again
it's still before the court so i just am
not able to comment further thanks dr
intro we'll go to the next caller
thank you carly robert robinson city
news
hi dr hincha um both the oilers and the
calgary flames are in the playoffs and
it's the first time in years that they
will have full crowds
for the playoffs i'm wondering what
advice you have to both fans as well as
stadiums with managing
the next few weeks of large crowds with
the levels of kobe we have in our
community
it's an important question and whether
it's attending one of these games or
whether it's attending other events in
our communities it's really important to
look at the information that's available
online to determine what the current
level of transmission is
so people can look at wastewater data
for different communities that's
available at the university of calgary
site as well as a summary that's
available on our government website
you can look at the geographic weekly
updates just get a sense of what is
transmission like at a given moment in
time we know right now that transmission
while plateauing is still at a high
level and so it's really important for
people who might be attending to
consider what precautions would be
appropriate for them for their risk
factors
and
you know again trying to think through
what
their exposure might be
and it's important for the people who
are supporting the fans uh to be
considering that there may be people who
have higher risk who want to still
attend
and so if there
is a
an opportunity to be able to support
those people that would be very
important to do so
thanks for that doctor
carly follow up
yeah i'm just wondering dr ginta if with
the these large events because they are
such big crowds what your recommendation
would be for
for those steps individuals can take and
and if you were to attend a game what
would be your thought process and what
steps would you do take to keep yourself
safe
so maybe i'll start by steps to keep
other people safe and say that if
someone is feeling ill at all if they're
feeling like they have a
sore throat runny nose a cough they
should absolutely not attend the game
and i think that's something that
stadium owners or those who are
supporting the the people who are
attending um can consider what their
processes might be we do still have
legal
isolation orders in place that require
those who have respiratory illness to be
at home and away from others so that
would be one thing again that would be
important to consider to minimize the
chances that someone who is actively
infectious would be attending
then with respect to someone who's
attending thinking about how to protect
themselves
wearing the
highest quality mask they have certainly
in a large public space like that if if
i were to attend i would want to be sure
to wear a medical grade mask at minimum
and then just considering the
environment and making sure that
people have perhaps hand sanitizer with
them and considering what their options
are in terms of seating and if there's
places where they might be able to watch
the game a little bit further away from
others
so ultimately it's all about multiple
layers of protection and there's no
single intervention that will guarantee
safety and attending a game where
there's many many people present
or attending any event going to any kind
of setting where there's many many
people present there will always be some
risk and so it's a matter of assessing
that risk comfort taking the precautions
that are
appropriate for who that person is
and also really importantly trying to
reduce the risk for those around others
by
again as i mentioned at the beginning
staying home with sick
thanks dr hill we'll take the next
question please
stephanie thomas ctv
hello my first question is for dr
henshaw in light of a new study from the
university of toronto that shows that
the unvaccinated disproportionately pose
a coded risk to those who are vaccinated
what is your advice after hainshot to
vaccinated people for hanging out with
those who are not that particularly
those who chose to be unvaccinated and
not talking about children that are too
young for the shot
it's very clear that vaccines are the
most powerful tool we have in our
efforts to prevent kovitch from
overwhelming our acute care system from
causing massive severe outcomes so
it's really important to emphasize that
at the same time
at this point in time we know that
those who have the protections of all
the vaccines that they're eligible for
have a reduced risk of severe outcomes
themselves and so i think that decision
is really best left to individuals who
are
assessing how to move forward this has
been a very divisive time
and i think that
everyone in their families and friends
groups
is working out how do we move forward
when we have differences of opinion on
different topics and so that's really
something that people need to kind of
weigh out how they're going to move
forward what are the
differences in risks that
they might be willing to take now that
maybe they wouldn't have been willing to
take a year or two ago
and ultimately
i continue to think it's really really
important to remember that
we
need to treat people with respect
even if they've made a different
decision than we have
again clearly there's
very solid evidence showing the
importance of vaccines and yet there are
many different reasons why someone may
have chosen to not receive a vaccine and
it will i think
be of most benefit to all of us as
communities and as a society if we can
uh reach across our differences have
respectful conversations and try to
understand where each other is coming
from
thanks dr
stephanie follow up
if i could direct this to house minister
jason coughing um just seeing that there
have been 90 more people admitted to
hospital and non-icu settings
what is the health ministry considering
them to support the hospital system in
this case what's being considered
yeah well thanks so much for the
question and
we understand that a number of hospitals
particularly um
the emergency departments
are under honor under strain um you know
working
with
with senior executive at an ahs and sort
of you know asking the plans they're
putting in place i understand
particularly in calgary we've seen this
strain in a number of hospitals
particularly on the in the emergency
departments of adding additional
additional beds to be able to uh to
manage through that and additional
resources plus you know doing work
through
you know moving people through the
hospital system as quickly and and as is
safe to do so um but we you know take a
step back you know we know that you know
our systems uh particularly in our big
hospitals in the cities um are under
strain uh typically this uh uh you know
this time of this time of year
um this is not new it's and it's it's
what's different here today uh is that
we do have uh we do have covert although
when we look at our total numbers it's
not higher than in previous
previous times uh when we're under this
much much strain uh but we've been you
know people are tired uh plus we have
people uh who are working in our
facilities who are off sick uh so short
term you know adding some initial
capacity uh and then moving people
through the quickly to the system as
quickly as possible the medium term and
long term really is about adding
capacity to our overall system
and that's what we're doing you know 600
million dollars additional but to the
budget this year
and then we're wrapping that for the
next few years
you know additional capacity for ems for
continuing care for acute care
additional 100 million dollars for icu
beds and then being flexible enough so
we can use those resources uh assigned
to icu beds either for surgeries or
non-icu as required but that's taking
time so we fully appreciate the system
is under strain right now uh ahs is
taking actions to be able to reduce
estrogen to help us get through this
wave but really it's about investing
more capacity longer term to be able to
manage whether it be a coveted wave or a
severe flu wave down the future so you
know people aren't doing the high dives
uh in
the sheer amount of overtime in the
future
thanks minister i believe we have two
reporters left on the phone we'll go to
the second last one please
david staples in general
oh thank you for taking my call
um dr henshaw we often hear the phrase
told it is here to stay
that's what this means for example in
terms of individual health so the mean
will all be repeatedly exposed to the
cold environment in coming years and
decades
i think the most likely scenario is that
we will as a as a population continue to
be exposed to covert virus
it will
likely be
more prevalent in the fall and winter
months when we typically see respiratory
viruses circulate more
just like influenza has for many many
years
what we don't know of course is the
impact that viral evolution will have
and how new variants of concern might
interact with our population so there
remain unknowns about covid
but ultimately what we have seen
especially with the past couple of waves
is that again vaccines are incredibly
effective at minimizing severe outcomes
and
that as we go forward we'll need to
continue to
monitor the evidence about not only the
effectiveness of our current vaccines
but whether there are new products that
might be able to help us
with additional
protection and whether there's new
therapeutics that can also help people
with early treatment so there will
continue to be changes and updates to
evidence as we go along
but the the bottom line is that i think
all of us will need to think about if
we're in a time where cohort
transmission is high what are our risks
and how do we protect ourselves and then
if we're in a time where covert
transmission is low that may be the time
where those who have risk factors are
able to do more without adding those
layers of protection so we need to be
able to
i guess flex our our response based on
what our current environment is
thanks dr hitchhiker a follow-up david
from given that colgate sounds like it's
here today for for coming here
what what safety measures
um do you think are also here to stay
that will become kind of staples of our
life
or our exact same energy suggested might
might
vary over time
i think that it will remain important
for all of us to think about how our
actions impact other people so
being mindful of how connected we all
are i think is something that
i would
like to see as being here to stay and so
that
includes
trying to
continue to reinforce
an expectation or a culture or supports
that allow people who are feeling sick
to stay home and not have to go to work
so things like like that i would hope
will be around for a long time to come
it's difficult to say what would be
required in in the future i think that
again
what we've seen to date is the
population impact has been reduced
because we have
strong vaccine coverage and if we're
able to maintain that
the
need to have
mandatory measures will be mitigated
for individuals again i think that it
will change over time and i i would
recommend that people continue to
monitor what that transmission level is
like and to use that as one factor in
determining what activities they they
wish to take
and of course that will factor into the
recommendations that are provided at a
provincial level
depending on what variants of concern
may emerge depending on what new
treatments may become available
there will continue to be evolving
recommendations again based on the the
evidence that's available at any moment
in time
thanks dr inshallah we'll take one last
call please
thank you bill kaufman post media
hi thanks um this uh questions for um
the ministry coughing
um i'm just wondering is the province
going to be appealing um
justice romain's decision
on
cabinet confidentiality and what do you
think of that decision
yeah as as
so my understanding is that the the
decision is being assessed but it's you
know still a live matter so i can't
comment further on
thanks minister uh bill follow
uh yeah this is a changing theory this
one's for um
dr hinshaw um after each other there
seems to be
really a large number of
outbreaks in long-term care facilities
how much of a concern is that
facilities where
seniors especially those who have
multiple complex medical conditions are
all living together
in a single space are of course have
always been and still are one of the
highest risk settings in our community
it's why we have maintained a level of
precautions in those settings
that is higher than anywhere else right
now
it is concerning that we are seeing
additional outbreaks we know that when
transmission in the community rises we
tend to see increasing outbreaks in
continuing care in other settings
it's
positive that given the high
vaccination rates in those facilities
the
case hospitalization rates and case
death rates are much lower than they
were in previous waves and yet it is
still of course very concerning which is
part of the reason why over the last two
weeks we've been rolling out fourth
doses to residents in those settings to
ensure that they have that additional
layer of protection at this time
and of course continuing to monitor and
work with facilities our local public
health teams work with facilities to
put interventions in place when there is
an outbreak to minimize further spread
but ultimately the
peace that all of us can do to prevent
those kinds of severe outcomes
especially if any of us have a loved one
who lives in that kind of a setting is
to make sure that we're mindful of the
rules that are in place that we follow
them
and it's particularly important that
anyone who's feeling a little bit sick
even with mild respiratory symptoms not
go into those settings to visit to try
to do everything we can to minimize the
chance of introducing the virus
and causing those outbreaks
so thanks dr hinshaw and minister we'll
wrap it up there and see you back here
next week